- All right, Key and
Peele, man, all right.
You know, we have some
bad blood at the end
of this season and
everything, right,
'cause we got mad at your shit,
'cause y'all didn't hire
us, but you know what?
We gonna bury the ax,
and not even worry
about it no more, man,
just seriously, like we
just making this tape now
as a audition, see how
good our writing is.
We've been brainstorming,
and what not,
so we just gonna throw
some ideas out to you,
and then, also, like maybe
do like a little scene
and everything for
y'all, all right?
- You gon' do it.
- What?
- Nigga, you said you
gon' do this with me.
- Nah, nah.
You gon' do it.
Just do it alone.
- Mike, I can't play
both characters.
- Yeah, you can.
I seen you do it.
- Nigga, when you
see me do that?
Man, you done it wit me
when the camera's off.
- That's why.
It's sill on, man.
I ain't doin' that shit, man.
That's stupid.
- This is some bullshit.
(beep)
Um.
I'm gonna need this,
I'm gon' need to send
a search team down
to the atmosphere.
- Yes, Captain, and when
you do that, please,
phase down deck two to
the surface of the planet.
- That's a good idea, Bortron.
Did you want to phase
your dick down there?
- Out.
- That's good, man.
Hey, can I tell
you something, dog?
You did that man, and the
camera was on and everything,
man.
We recorded that whole thing.
- Erase that shit, nigga.
- Why, man?
That sounded good, dog.
- Nah, nigga.
Erase that shit, man.
Erase it.
Come on, man.
- This mother...
Key and Peele, man, you
just watched us do a scene
together, man.
Now y'all understand, man.
We got talent, and you
should hire us, man.
I mean, we have whole
lots of bunch of ideas
for scenes, man.
We got Robodick.
We got Dick Time Machine.
Fart Gun.
That's what we was reading from.
- Two Thousand and Dick.
- Two Thousand and Dick, man.
Dickasaurus Rex.
- I Am Fart Legend.
- Johnny Dooky and
the Socky Socks.
- Eddy and the Dick Cruiser.
- Indiana Jones and
Temple of Dicks.
- Matrix Dicks.
- Place in the Dick.
- Dicks is spelled with a X.
- The Empire Strikes Dick.
- Schindler's Dick.
Planet of the Farts.
- Planet of the Dicks.
- And then we got
Farts of the Dicks.
- Farts of the Dicks, man.
(laughing)
Listen, we just keep
pumping them out.
Keep pumpin' 'em out.
It's pretty easy, man.
All you gotta do is
take almost any name,
just put dick
somewhere in there.